Бабця спитьі не реагує на візити
спочатку одного, а потім другогокандидата в президенти.
Але раптом прокидається, коли їй пропонують гречку.
Дівчина уся в шоколаді мотивує чоловіків віддати голос за "солодке".
Так звані вуличні політологи б’ються через суперечку:
хтожкращий з кандидатів. Той, що підвищує пенсію більше,
чи інший, який знижує ціни на газ.
Меми на політичну тему зараз в тренді.
А 20-тирічний Микита Шевченко радий,
що його стартап - мобільний додаток про меми -
привносить у занадто напружену ситуацію напередодні виборів трохи гумору.
Сатира, на думку Микити, допомагає усвідомити
занадто високий рівень популізму в українській політиці.
Ця передвиборна кампанія - це просто якийсь каламбур.
Те, як кандидати до цього ставляться, це просто смішно.
От ми йдемо по вулиці і бачимо білборд,
мовляв, я знижу ціни на газ вдвічі.
Потім бачимо наступний, який нам говорить, що знизить в чотири рази.
І ти такий: ух-ти! Я, мабуть, оберу другого.
В такому дусі.
Це мене веселить, але, водночас, дуже засмучує.
31 березня Микита буде голосувати вперше
і ставиться до цього серйозно.
Принаймні, з кандидатом він давно визначився.
Хоча не вважає його тим, хто буде сильно перейматися інтересами молоді.
Серед майже 40 кандидатів в президенти взагалі немає таких,
переконана і студентка факультету політології
Києво-Могилянської академії Ірина Засімович.
Їй 19, вона теж голосує вперше.
І до справи підійшла серйозно:
ознайомилася з програмами кандидатів, аналізувала,
хто за них піде голосувати.
Серед кандидатів багато оулдтаймерів, і вони,
на думку майбутньої політологині, не привабливі для молоді.
Тож, Ірина дещо згодна з деякими прогнозами,
що 15-30% молоді можуть на вибори не прийти,
або прийти і зіпсувати бюлетені.
Зараз внас найактивніші пенсіонери.
Студенти - вони не дуже зацікавленів тому, щоб піти на вибори.
І ми маємоот цю нерівність подолати,
прийти на вибори, збільшити явку студентів.
Адже тоді дуже великий "шіфт"
йде в сторону кандидатів, яких підтримують
більш вікове населення,і це не дуже добре.
Владиславу 21 рік. Він вже має робочу спеціальність
і вчиться далі, щоб отримати вищу кваліфікацію спеціаліста з деревообробки.
Він теж голосує вперше, і теж зі своїм кандидатом визначився.
Він, як Ірина і Микита, вважає себе поколінням,
на яке дуже вплинули події на Майдані,
які показали, як молодь може змінити і країну,
і думки тих же пенсіонерів.
ож, у Владислава до президента, якого обере Україна,
доволі серозні вимоги на наступні 5 років.
Я хочу бачити сліпу Феміду,
але не сліпих поліцейських.
Я хочу бачити пенсіонерів,
які не беруть гречку на наступних виборах.
Я хочу бачити політиків,
які йдуть в кандидати на наступних виборах, які не дискредитовані,
про яких не випливають компромати перед виборами.
Я не хочу чути про те, що політик щось вкрав.
Я хочу чути про те, що того політика вже посадили.
20-тирічна Марія часто витрачає півтори години,
аби доїхати зі свого рідного селища Козин до Києва.
Вона отримала спеціальність перукаря,
але не змогла цим заробляти на життя.
Нині вирішила займатися квітами і працює в теплиці "Київзеленбуду".
Марія хоче піти проголосувати просто за краще майбутнє.
Особисто вона від новообраного президента багато не очікує
і має лише одну вимогу.
Я нічого не очікую, надіюся на себе,
сама зможу все зробити.
…щоб закінчилася війна. Це для держави саме головне.
Студентка "Могилянки", студент профучилища, робітниця "Київзеленбуду"
і розробник стартапу. Усі вони хочуть повернення
окупованих територій, незмінного курсу на ЄС і НАТО, продовження реформ.
Інакше на молодь очікує ось таке майбутнє, як на цьому мемі,
який нещодавно запостили в додатку Микити.
Він не хоче, аби молодь залишала країну.
Інакше владу в Україні справді обиратимуть лише пенсіонери.